Let's talk about the movie "Public Enemies".
It's a great story,...
...and I think there was an era in this country when this was fairly common.
After the depression, early 30s,...
...we had outlaws who became folk heroes and this is about John Dillinger and his buddies.
I saw the movie the other night and really enjoyed it. It's fantastic.
I like it because historically, it's the real deal, you know?
And then have you seen the movie?
No, I have not.
I'm sorry, you've not seen the movie?
Not just yet.
You're too busy to see it probably?
You know, in a way, once my job is done on a film, it's really none of my business.
Really, none of your business?
So, you deliberately don't look at the finished product?
Oh yeah, I stay as far away as I possibly can.
Is that right?
Yeah.
If I can, I'd try to stay in as profound a state of ignorance as possible.
Well, you've come to the right place.
You're exactly where you need to be.